peaceful hunger squad back at it again
gonna drive all over Los Angeles and
look for the best PB&J sandwich but
instead of our usual telephone we
wouldn't play literal telephone but we
will be telephoning Keith to ask where
to go twice key to the video all of a
sudden who cares that's why we're mixing
it up and because today feast mode for
work gets to eat peanut butter and I'm
jelly if you haven't noticed I'm white
therefore I've eaten more peanut butter
and jelly sandwiches than anything else
the most important thing in a peanut
butter jelly sandwich is peanut butter -
jelly your ratio you may have noticed
that I am leaning against the good old
nacho wagon making its second appearance
in feast mode hunger squad Miley
favorite van PB&J alright get in the van
guys alright so we are on our way to
Mendocino farms right now we're about to
eat peanut butter and jelly on quinoa
millet bread so basically they don't put
the PB&J on their menu because they're
hoping that it's just gonna grow by word
of mouth secret hidden items and now
we're telling the world
the white bread version thus far to me
that is like the classic PB&J I love the
flavor love the crunch let's not sleep
on the gluten-free it's really good it's
actually kind of tastes like PB&J on
like a Triscuit or like a weak pin the
ratio is actually perfect yeah it's a
slightly more jelly time peanut butter
I'm too cocky guys
hello key hahaha how are you I'm
fantastic
I was the kids menu PB&J definitely one
of the best kids menu PB and J's I've
ever had
well that's incredible now I'm sending
you somewhere we can actually order off
the adult menu you're headed to Joan's
on third go to Joan's on third I just
ordered our four peanut butter jelly
sandwiches yo all right Joan's on third
decided to get all LA on us and say we
can't shoot without a location sign-off
from blah blah what what we're eating in
the van what have you done in this van
other than eating it you don't want to
know okay moving on so they gave us
these dainty delicious looking little
peanut butter and jelly sandwiches they
smell good they have good weight to them
already off the bat it seems like I had
too much peanut butter but it really
isn't like that's special like this
isn't taste like gourmet yeah I mean I'm
bored by it the bread is like perfectly
toasted though better Cole keep
hello key haha hello Colin how's it
going Joan's on third was kind of a
bummer let me make it up to you you're
gonna go to doughboys which is nearby
it's also on 3rd doughboys cafe on 3rd
remember that this is an exquisite
peanut butter and jelly sandwich I
believed it's either fried grilled or
baked a whole bunch of stuff is going
into it you're gonna love it or at least
we hope you do so we just try to go to
doughboys to get their gourmet peanut
butter chocolate banana sandwich which
is I heard amazing they wouldn't allow
it to film so we're gonna get those
joints to go and I guess head back to
the orange van literally what they do is
they take all the ingredients peanut
butter chocolate jelly bananas they
stuff it all together on the bread they
dip it in egg batter and then they grill
that it picked that sandwich they bake
it a little bit longer so that baked
together
I serve it to you that's why I take so
long oh my god I will say that this
thing is so overwhelming look I don't
even know what I'm tasting I'm into it
though and I love the banana aspect you
know what the problem is guys what
peanut butter jelly ratio one thing I
know is that this won't taste as good
cold so let's get a hot one back to
Keith right now oh my gosh oh my gosh
guys if you have a good adventure okay
cuz I hmm
well they did it those beasties feasted
the [ __ ] out of those sandwiches and
they brought me one which means in the
end all you viewers are jelly wait a
minute it wasn't that menacing to farms
unlike the really good one yeah this why
do you put me that one you should've
come with us we're not your powder puff
girls come on we'll put the powder puff
girl yeah you don't notice the city go
to your dirty wife is that your go to
you be with you pink powder puff girl
fan Steven yes